is it getting easier to be a rock band
with instruments and actually that plays
music and everything because it seems
like more and more people are shifting
to electronic music and then and that
rock acts are not having spots to get
that sort of a public display that they
used to and I don't know if it's because
companies have figured out it's cheaper
to just send people with electronics and
we really know really cheap no I think
about every night for us bands aren't
really dying out what's happening is
people are trying to figure out ways to
kind of do amalgamation of modern and an
old you know I mean I think the modern
music had it right first when all the
dance music was getting samples from
like the 1950s and putting it on top of
the electronic mm-hm
so then you were you're bringing to John
Rose together and now what's happening
is a lot of bands are paying heed to
what's contemporary and adding that to
their music so they actually they did
the flip part first we were just
following suit a lot of bands were
thinking about how do you meet a
generation today you know you don't want
to just talk to people that know exactly
what you know about music you want to
learn you gotta meet people in the
middle if you want to have those people
be carter part of your family right yeah
I know that makes a lot of sense we will
never die that way you just have to be
there waiting for it cuz it's coming it
will be everything moves in cycles right
brewing right under the surface it's
always gonna be there that just waiting
for it to come back you just hope it
comes back though like you this probably
a hair metal guy right now is pushing
looking for that bar somewhere
how long you guys been together we've
been together for seven years come on
that's a relatively young band two of
two I know you guys toured with the
stones as well like you've had some
major exposure which is great but for a
kind of a young band that's that's
pretty impressive
it all happened the first year hosting
ever since then do you guys have any
trouble being in a band is difficult
because - for this fight of you is it's
like a five-way marriage so is there any
like like oh [ __ ] we should break up or
do you guys
good working relationship I think just
like a marriage you have you make it
work and it's always great and I think
sometimes in there are bumps that lead
you to doing something interesting and
new in order to work it out and you
always end up better on the other side
but get together for a billion dollars
what happens in a band where a billion
dollars doesn't convince you to get back
together
that's crazy I don't I don't when you
have three billion you don't need the
extra 1 billion that's probably it how
great would it event by the way if you'd
ask that question and one of them had
been like no everything's good and at
the same time the other ones going yeah
no no thanks for bad I was hoping for
was like crying in the corner I was
telling you guys before we got on the
air that uh I'm a fan of your band and I
I didn't I I became a fan of the band
because of production that we were doing
like for the show that I sometimes don't
know our production guy Troy like just
finds cool new music and he and he puts
elements of it into the production stuff
that we do and I had no idea that you
guys were responsible for some of that
but you are and then we're responsible
for all of it all of it
you guys want to perform something for
us absolutely not thank you bye all
right well thanks for stopping by the
album is available would that be great
they told us to go [ __ ] ourselves with
the billion dollars anyway so this song
is a song called doing what you do and
it's a song we kind of wrote according
to an event that happened on Venice
Beach one magical Sunday afternoon and
there was this police altercation and
the cop broke up the crowd me said all
right everybody get back to doing what
you're doing
oh and then and so then I was like I'd
be a great title because you know how
often in life whether it be a
relationship or whether it be after work
is over or once you've gotten through a
major interesting all of a sudden you're
like oh god I'm back at my flow let me
get back to doing what I was doing and I
think a lot of people related it was
really funny there's this little girl on
the beach one time when we were writing
it and I asked her you know how's this
phrase sound to you and I was like all
right everybody get back to do what you
do and she's like is it doing what
you're doing everybody
your home come on come on feel it feel
it all right now everybody just packed
it to it what you are doing
everybody just get back to doing what
you do why don't we love ourselves to be
the legends while we're living where our
hands we he'll tell me where life was
home live or TV you gotta carry on carry
on doctor carry on
all right now everybody just be back to
doing what you were doing you see what
are you just get back to doing what you
would do lay down your arms lower your
shoulders and beat up the war that tore
us apart but they can't change the fact
that we roll each other you gotta carry
or carry over just back to do it
watch what do it praise praise but you
see what I mean
all right now everybody just back to
what you were
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right now everybody just be back to
doing what you're doing you see what I
mean
do you see what I mean
[Music]
you see what I see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that was awesome man
and I want to be in a band yeah right
with that but just have musical ability
at all or comedic ability thank you now
obviously the the performing part in the
morning is difficult for you for you the
singer is always the one who has to like
get their voice ready in the morning and
normally they don't sound that amazing
[ __ ] this early I use yeah I like
singing in the morning you do is that
right yeah you got you got a sound it's
like one of those things like you know
you watch all those old black and white
movies and people get out of the band
singing yeah if you just convince
yourself I'm just in like some 1950s
movie and can the Sun really rise
without voice and song yeah the answer's
no and so you're just saying just do it
it comes out you feel good about it
you're promoting a tour as well you have
a bunch of dates here
October 13th 14th in New York you're in
Bloomington Illinois where can they go
to get all of your dates so we can
promote or is it your website is vintage
trouble dot-com okay yeah go there and
you can also have a Milwaukee st. Paul
Chicago Toronto Detroit Indianapolis all
these coming up in there promote the new
single is knocked me out and are you
guys gonna do that one too yeah but
first um we're gonna pay homage to you -
yeah promotion song which is a song
called Blues hand-me-down
it's actually the song where we got our
band name from and a a friend of mine
was asking me we're going to the airport
and she was like was your dad trouble
and I said my dad has vintage trouble
you know and at that time we were
writing the song and I wrote a line in
it
I come from vintage trouble lookout if
I'm the one you found and so all of a
sudden you know it felt all like you
know we come from vintage trouble like
it was a band name so we just took it on
with a song line actually came first Wow
that a song this song named the band and
do you want us to do that now Charlotte
love absolutely yeah okay but here's the
thing we did this acoustic album so it's
gonna be a little different version you
used to hear and sure but hey mix your
head up it's time for change I come from
village trouble look out I found the one
you found I pop your bubble with my live
wide street shooting dirty mouth
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
no mercy on my soul
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
have mercy on my soul
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yes amazing violets left on live
like see the harmonies all come together
like you hear it on a recording and you
imagine that it's just like studio
pieces no I know it's like porno
magazines and strip clubs
that's it together really really great
thank you
seriously because a lot of times bands
come in it's kind of harder for them to
you know be performers not the ideal
setting absolutely or the the acoustic
version is really like totally just
stripped down to nothing right okay okay
yeah I wish I could say it like it must
be fun just to sing like covers of [ __ ]
you like it must just be fun to be able
to sing it be musical you just want to
sing like Ozzy if there was if there was
one song we will say like you know you
did have that talent that you say you
don't have what would with that song be
for you in your dreams what is that song
what's the shower song with the brush in
front of the mirror what's the air
guitar so who is a there was the one
song who would it be
I would probably have to say the
Birmingham jail
oh by who it's an old so I was in
stir-crazy and it's a guy it was signed
by grossberger you guys rooster crazy
Richard Pryor and Gene Wilder what's
that Curtis Mayfield did the crazy
he might have is this one they took from
the film actually there's this big
monster of a man could actually sing was
it great
my grandmother took me to see that and
when they started Kirstie how's it going
[ __ ] the old bags gonna drag me out
so I would like mincing too I would like
to hear the new single I would really
want a that everybody's talking about oh
my god I keep hearing about this new
single and I'm like I got to hear alive
cool part about this song for us is that
you know we wrote it a few months before
Muhammad Ali passed away and we weren't
really thinking about it being something
that would be that would remind us about
fighting because at that time if you
remember a lot of crazy stuff had not
quite picked up yet like it has now and
so now besides it being a song about the
greatest Muhammad Ali it's also a song
that's a tough love
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] awesome Wow god damn guys I'm
out it's really really great thank you
yeah I mean you guys are tremendous holy
[ __ ] there's good man I really like that
was really great